Володимирівна європейську
Солідарність Дякую Шановні колеги дійсно
Україну накриває перша хвиля пандемією
більше 300 000 інфікованих сьогодні
рекорд
4766 випадків і Україна вже дев'ята в
цьому трагічному списку країн вісім
місяців тому Верховна Рада України
перерахувала з бюджету 65 млрд грн на
боротьбу з пандемією за цей час Влада
Зеленського не закупила жоден новий швл
не встановила жодне КТ не подбала про те
щоб в лікарнях стояли не просто ліжка і
лікарі звідти не тікали Тому що їм
ніяких доплат і страхувань ніхто не
виплачує а не подбала про кисневі маски
Про підведення кисню про а доступні
тести і власне це говорить про повну
імпотенцію влади в питаннях вирішення
ключової на сьогодні безпекової проблеми
ми вимагаємо створення тска про викори
стання коштів які були направлені на
ковід а також наша фракція зареєструвала
Постанову в якій ми вимагаємо негайного
звіту від Зеленського який в березні
створив Координаційний штаб який ми
бачимо не займався нічим весь цей час
звіту про використання коштів відповіді
Що робила місцева влада в цей час яка
отримала серйозні кошти від
децентралізації але так само діяла
неефективно в питанні боротьби з ковідом
ми вимагаємо що би всі 65 млрд грн були
направлені на боротьбу з ковід а не
велике крадівництво де без тендерів
сьогодні латають дороги і чомусь ці
латання коштують в два-три рази дорожче
ніж за попередньої влади знаєте от в
останньому інтерв'ю bbсі Зеленський
рефлексував Що Порошенко і досі вважає
себе президентом проблема в іншому в
тому що Зеленський і досі вважає себе
кандидатом в президенти часів
президентства Порошенка і працює
сьогодні не не президентом держави
займаючись безпековою політикою
займаючись армією і боротьбою з ковід а
vip-агітатором слух інакше ніяк не можна
пояснити те на що вже тичуть його носом
громадські організації в тому числі
опора що він займається прихованою
агітацію коли штампами передвиборчих
гасел слух виступає з трибуни не з
Державної символікою де написана зє
Чомусь я перепрошую мова йде про
президента України яке б не було його
прізвище цікаві дуже ци
надає організація опора що на цей час
поліція зареєструвала вже більше 2900
порушень в той час як Президентські
вибори 19-го року було 614 порушень
парламентські 537 Схоже що останні чесні
вибори в цій країні відбулися за часів
президентства Порошенка Зараз ми бачимо
понівечені борди європейської
солідарності Романа сущенка в Черкасах
нашого кандидата в Полтаві по всій
країні ми бачимо абсолютно злочинна
відмову реєструвати опозиційних
кандидатів в тому числі в Кременчузі
навіть після рішень суду і в цей час
президент замість того щоб гарантувати
чесні вибори займається
псевдоопитуванням з незрозумілими
джерелами фінансування якщо в президента
є зайві кошти нехай направить їх на
боротьбу з ковід я нагадаю що Порошенко
100 млн грн направив в 200 лікарень щоби
за забезпечити лікарів захисними
костюмами і досі вони ними користуються
якщо це меценатські кошти нехай
Зеленський попросить своїх друзів
меценатів переправити це на боротьбу з
ковід А якщо він дуже хоче якісь питання
вирішити в нього є право законодавчо
ініціативи і це можна робити через
абсолютно законний шлях абсолютно е
недосконало звучать заяви про те що
бюджет не буде розглядатись через
хворобу депутатів я нагадаю що ми
прийняли закон про можливість проведення
комітетів в онлайн-режимі і це абсолютно
не ковід тут винен А те що маємо
абсолютно недолугу монобільшість Ми
хочемо подякувати Юлії Тимошенка і іншим
колегам які підготували Постанову яка по
суті враховує багато пунктів
запропонованих Порошенком в контексті
боротьби з ковідом єдине ми пропонуємо
щоби до цієї постанови ми об'єднали наші
дві постанови були долучені кілька речей
не створення нової координаційної ради а
звіід Зеленського який вже створив свою
координаційну Раду Ще вісім місяців тому
так само захист лікарів повернення 5
млрд грн до освітніх до освітнього фонду
для того щоби там в школах і
університетах боролися з ковідом а не
крали ці гроші кожен регіон має
представити Свій маленький фонд до рівня
отг по боротьбі з ковідом держава має
запропонувати стратегію боротьби з
пандемією Ми чекаємо звіту уряду нам
необхідні доступні тести і власне ми
пропонуємо дійсно об'єднати Ці дві
постанови щоби все це було враховано що
стосується завтрашнього рекламного
передвиборчого виступу Зеленського то ми
очікуємо що там буде саме звіт